[Musik]
[Applaus]
am 24 februar überfällt russland die
ukraine
als die ersten raketen in kiew
einschlagen bricht chaos in der
millionen metropole aus
[Musik]
ich bin um sechs von den explosionen
aufgebracht alle waren in panik ich hab
das fenster aufgemacht und geschaut die
leute waren wie verrückt mit taschen
unterwegs sie sind alle aus den häusern
gekommen und haben lebensmittel
eingekauft alle waren in panik
bis zu diesem morgen für tallinn akku
china mit ihrem mann alexander und der
siebenjährigen tochter alissa das leben
an der typischen kiel familie aus der
mittelschicht
man muss überall ist das war alles gut
bei uns wir hatten vor im märz um mehr
zu
danach wollten wir im april in paris
meinen 35 geburtstag feiern wir hatten
unsere traum zwei autowerkstätten ich
hatte meinen schönheitssalon das kind
hat die schule besucht
[Musik]
am 24 februar endet ihr familienglück
ich habe mich dazu entschlossen darüber
zu sprechen
damit die menschen wissen was bei uns in
wirklichkeit passiert
ich lasse mich auf das interview ein
damit alle sehen und wissen
dass bei uns die menschen erschossen ist
vergewaltigt werden
dass schreckliches passiert
am ersten kriegstag flüchten alina und
ihre familie aus kiew verteilt auf zwei
autos verlassen sie die stadt alexander
fährt mit dem nexus
vogel
alina und ihre tochter nehmen in mazda
ziel ist ein wochenendhaus von freunden
die deutsche liegt im ort die mit rifka
sechs kilometer westlich vom käfer
stadtrand über die schickte mir
autobahnen gut zehn minuten zu erreichen
die familie hofft auf dem land vor den
russischen luftschlägen sicher zu sein
wenige kilometer weiter an der skipiste
autobahn erstreckt sich ein weiteres
deutschen gebiet der ort heißt mir
heilig karubi schiff kam
mit kriegsausbruch fliehen auch in
dieser siedlung immer mehr menschen aus
kiew klar domenico lightshow und das
ganze jahr hier in seiner deutsche
der rentner blickt auf ein bewegtes
leben zurück den abend auf seiner stirn
zeugen davon
strahlenkrankheit
ich war liquidator
von 1986 bis 1988 musste wladimir
nicolai job den reaktor des explodierten
kernkraftwerk sichern
das ist das ergebnis der starken
strahlung früher hatte ich am ganzen
körper diese wunden
der krieg wird den 71 jährigen noch
einmal zum helden machen schon am ersten
tag des russischen angriffs wird es eng
in seiner datsche 29 menschen haben dort
zuflucht gefunden auch die familie
seines sohnes
hasen spricht deutsch
entschieden dass durch diese ganze
sicher kann man noch ein problem leben
und ich habe meine familie ein besten
tag zu meinem vater zu bild ich war 100
prozent sicher dass meine familie in
sicherheit ist
nicolai zugpferd nach kiew zurück als
leutnant der reserve will er sich für
die verteidigung seiner startbereit hat
vor den russischen luftangriffen auf die
hauptstadt fliehen auch maxim janko und
seine frau xenia ist russin geboren auf
der krim mit ihren sechsjährigen sohn
flüchtete das paar zu freunden ebenfalls
in die deutschen siedlung von michaelis
cargo geschäft
über ihr schicksal kann maximus sehen ja
selbst nicht mehr berichten das paar
wird auf der ski thomas k autobahn von
russischen soldaten auf der flucht
erschossen
die deutschen siedlungen westlich von
kiew werden zur tödlichen falle
gucken wir uns die situation in kiew
etwas genauer an vom norden her kam der
haupt angriff stoß mit etwa 20 bis 25
taktisch und religionsgruppen und einer
unter einer taktischen religionsgruppe
muss man sich vorstellen zwei bis drei
panzer
schützenpanzer kompanien also
mechanisierte infanterie
+2 artillerie und zwei raketenwerfer
jede bataillons gruppe hat so etwa 800
oder knapp 1000 soldaten und damit
versuchte man dann also in kiew schnell
einzudringen allerdings eben
unvorbereitet im blick auf einen so
hartnäckigen ukrainischen widerstand
um den vorstoß der russin nach kiew zu
verhindern sprengten die ukraine bereits
am zweiten kriegstag die brücke über den
rp die deutschen siedlungen entlang der
thomasstraße drohen von der außenwelt
abgeschnitten zu werden immer wieder
fallen internet und telefon aus
ein von anwohnern heimlich gedrehtes
video es zeigt wie russische panzer
durch den deutschen vor ort michael
hruby schiff kapitulieren
alles rund kostenlos
im nachbarort niedriger wächst bei alina
cucina und ihrem mann alexander die
angst vor den russischen truppen
ein kleinsten geräusch sind wir in den
keller gerannt das waren viele leute was
mit alle sind gerannt wir hatten angst
die kinder hörten die schüsse und
explosionen
sie haben das alles verstanden
[Musik]
tage nach kriegsausbruch ist die lage
für die eingeschlossenen menschen in den
vororten völlig unklar die wenigen
informationen sind nicht verlässlich wer
noch strom und internet hat kommuniziert
über telefon
ist es jetzt möglich die südautobahn
fenster ja nachher innogy zu überqueren
ist dieser abschnitt gefährlich kannst
gerne pm schreiben geht heute noch
jemand diesen weg
es geht nicht über die straßen nur zu
fuß und durch den wald
beim plaudern nikolai kruk reifte der
gedanke dass die deutschen siedlung auf
dauer nicht sicher ist er beginnt
fluchtwege zu suchen
die lage scheint aussichtslos
seit tagen rücken russische streitkräfte
nach butter und in front
die brücke nach kiew gesprengt die
autobahn umkämpft
von domenico lightshow beobachtet die
russischen einheiten
ich bin in die hocke gegangen und habe
durch den spalt mit dem fernglas
geschaut um festzustellen in welcher
entfernung sich ihre patrouille befand
genauso in die andere und
dort wo die steller steht an tankstellen
laden dort war
die suche nach einer fluchtroute aus der
belagerten deutschen siedlung an der
schnellstraße für flotte mikolajczyk
wird sie zu einer lebensgefährlichen
mission
am dritten märz waren sich anwohner vor
russischen angriffen
es gibt informationen dass die schütte
mir autobahnen richtung kiew gesperrt
ist an welchem punkt ist unbekannt ein
bekannter hat gerade angerufen dass er
nicht vorbei konnte sie haben geschossen
es gab einen kampf an der kreuzung des
quarree de ski parkplatzes und es geht
jetzt weiter seid vorsichtig es gibt
eine sehr große kolonne feindliche
ausrüstung
ich glaube dass das gefecht direkt in
der nähe der tankstelle ist rauch steigt
von dort aus hatte durch wir werden alle
überleben
zwischen russischen und ukrainischen
einheiten gibt es schwere kämpfe auf der
skitour metzgerstraße
sie konzentrieren sich auf den kia
vororts tor janker kurz vor der
gesprengten brücke über den
12 uhr 55 eine amtliche warnung
achtung eine kolonne feindlicher
fahrzeuge bestehend aus 14 einheiten
bewegt sich entlang der schnellstraße
tunnel in richtung des dorfes der janka
bewahren sie ruhe und achten sie auf die
persönliche sicherheit sollte sich die
lage verschlechtern wird zusätzlich
alarm gegeben für alina kubina ihren
mann und tochter alissa kommen die
warnungen an diesem tag zu spät
wir haben keine kräfte mehr unter
solchen bedingungen zu bleiben wir
wollten nach hause
am vormittag des dritten märz verlässt
die dreiköpfige familie die datsche
alina mit dem weißen master tochter
alisa fährt bei ihrem vater alexander im
lexus mit
ich bin hinter ihm gefahren mein ehemann
sagte noch paare dicht hinter her ich
werde vorne fahren und du hinter mir und
dann sehe ich wie er beschleunigt
die ganze zeit aus dem fenster zu lehnen
gespielt sie waren zuerst nicht zu sehen
es wurde aus dem wald geschossen dann
kamen sie alle raus als sie anfingen zu
schießen könnten nicht nur so schnell
fahren
sein auto wurde beschossen die geschosse
trafen seine beine die lunge die brust
die beine wurden getroffen dann hat er
das auto angehalten
er hat an der haltestelle gestanden
auch seine tochter ist verletzt ein
projekt hier bleibt in alisas schulter
stecken
währenddessen rast alina richtung kiel
bald kommt sie nicht die brücke über den
penis gesprengt alina muss umkehren
wieder erreicht sie den lexus in dem ihr
mann um sein leben kämpft aus dem
rücksitz ihre verletzte tochter als ich
vorbei wir fahren bin wurde ich wieder
geschossen ich konnte nicht anhalten
verstehen sie
einige hundert meter vom lexus ihres
mannes entfernt kommt alina cucina von
der fahrbahn ab der mazda kollidiert mit
den leitplanken
ich hatte mit meinem leben schon
abgeschlossen wird angehalten
tür geöffnet
hände hoch gehoben ich denke unsere
armee werden wohl nicht schießen
dann sehe ich die kanone auf dem panzer
wahrscheinlich der hauptmann aus dem
zeichen dass ich zu ihm kommen soll was
sollte ich sonst mache ich
kniete er richtete die maschinenpistole
auf mich und sagte sprich ich schieße wo
sind die streitkräfte er richtete wie
maschinenpistole auf mich und ich musste
so bleiben vielleicht 57 minuten lang
und ich wusste nicht was ich machen soll
er erzielte und ich habe nur noch das
laden der waffe ich dachte er wird
sowieso schließen hab ich es weiß oder
nicht verwirkt schießen
alina kotina springt auf mehrere kugeln
treffen sie
[Musik]
ich bin vor ihm weggerannt tief in den
wald nicht ganz gerannt ich bin
hingefallen dann gebrochen
ich habe einen im rohbau befindliches
haus gesehen wenn dort rein
mir wurde schwarz vor augen mir war klar
dass ich gleich das bewusstsein
verlieren wir
im auto ihres ehemanns bricht feuer aus
seine frau alina ist nicht erreichbar
sie hatte telefon verloren
schwerverletzt wählt alexander kopien
die nummer seiner mutter
märz um 11 uhr mich mein sohn angerufen
und gesagt mama ist es vorbei ich sterbe
du musst ein enkelkind alisa gesprochen
ich antwortete
ist dann war doch alles in ordnung zum
anderen fort von hier und jetzt sagt er
meine beine bringen ich spüre den russen
nicht mehr das ist alles wir werden uns
nicht wiedersehen es war ein alptraum
es war schrecklich ich konnte es nicht
glauben
[Musik]
etwas war wo gott sei dank hat er noch
gelebt und konnte das fenster öffnen das
auto hat schon gebrannt und das kind
hätte lebendig verbrennen können
[Musik]
ich bin fast ersticken dann bin ich aus
dem auto dann sagte er zu mir schnell
mich an ich habe es versucht aber es hat
sich geklagt er heißt aus dem auto
gekrochen und hat mit dem bein den brand
im kofferraum murmelt und dann habe ich
gesehen dass seine beine brennen und
habe angefangen zu weinen meine tränen
sind geflossen
ich hatte angst ich hatte angst ein
menschen in diesem zustand zu sehen ich
bin dann losgerannt
die siebenjährige läuft in den wald und
stößt auf männer aus der umgebung das
mädchen erzählt was geschehen ist die
männer kämpfen sich zum tatort vor und
bergen alexander von der autobahn
schnell verbreitet sich im freundeskreis
was familie kopien zugestoßen ist
14 uhr 47 posten freunde eine
suchmeldung auf telefon
hallo hilfe bitte auf der autobahn jeton
mir in der nähe des parkplatzes wurden
zwei autos beschossen vielleicht hat
jemand diese frau gesehen sie waren
einem der autos
alina kotina wird gerettet einwohner des
dorfes kapital fk entdecken die schwer
verletzte frau bringen sie in eines der
letzten noch funktionierenden
krankenhäuser der gegend
die geschosse haben mir die hand und das
schlüsselbein zertrümmert
wissen panzer war dass russland von
russland unter schock berichtet sie den
ärzten was passiert ist
ich kniete nieder er fing an zu schießen
ich fing an wegzulaufen ich bin gelaufen
und gelaufen dann merkte ich dass mein
arm soll herunterbaumeln
[Musik]
indes ringen anwohner um das leben von
alexander koke immer wieder ruft seine
mutter an
die helfer halten ihrem sohn das telefon
in
[Musik]
ich sage so und er hat schon ganz
schwach geantwortet mama lebewohl mama
mama liebe wohl ich kann es nicht
glauben 35 jahre ist er geworden letztes
jahr 35 jahre für alexander kopien kommt
der rettungswagen zu spät er stirbt in
einem krankenhaus an den folgen der
schussverletzung
alina kotina droht die amputation ihres
armes alisa muss das geschoss aus dem
körper entfernt werden mutter und
tochter werden in einer klinik in
deutschland behandelt
am 4 märz wird die skier thomas k
schnellstraße erneut zur todesfalle
drohnen aufnahmen zeigen russische
panzer am tatort
[Musik]
nicole 120 kilometer von der stadtgrenze
entfernt auch von hier wollen menschen
fliehen
es ist um vierter märz passiert
ein freitag
der krieg hat uns auf der tasche
erwischt
und wir wollten zurück nach kiew
alena dbb war und ihr ehemann biegen
nahe des ortes boussoufa auf die
autobahn ab
das rentnerehepaar rechnet nicht damit
auf russische soldaten zu stoßen
drohnen aufnahmen zeigen die exakte
position der russischen panzer
wir hatten alle informationen gelesen
wie man sich an einem ukrainischen
posten verhält als wir von der
dorfstraße auf dieguito mascara autobahn
fuhren da kann man auf uns zu schießen
es war kein ukrainischer sondern ein
russischer post
die geschosse treffen olena lebedewa in
den oberkörper
ich wurde an der schulter verwundet der
zentrale nerven knoten wurde beschädigt
die knochen schlüsselbein zertrümmert
soweit mir erklärt wurde war es ein
explosives
man begann zu schreien wie soll ich
sagen wahrscheinlich stand er unter
schock er hat sie angeschrien
die soldaten geben der frau eine spritze
vermutlich morphium
sie lachten und fragten wie viele
kilometer sind es bis zum dorf ich
antwortete sechs na dann laufen sie los
sie wussten ja dass man mit so einer
verletzung keine 100 meter mehr schafft
so ging es auch nach 100 metern bin ich
gestürzt das war es dort habe ich
gelegen meine beine habe ich nicht mehr
gespürt ich war verwirrt übel ich habe
geblutet
das rentnerpaar wird von anderen
flüchtlingen gefunden
originale pd war kommt zunächst in ein
ukrainisches hospital
später schafft sie es gemeinsam mit
ihrer enkelin berlin dort werden ihre
schweren verletzungen in einem unfall
krankenhaus behandelt
[Musik]
auf dem drohnen material sind mehrere
zerstörte pkw zu erkennen aus der ferne
das sich nicht mit sicherheit sagen ob
der toyota- der familie b war darunter
ist
offenbar sind genau an dieser stelle
tage zuvor geflüchtete unter beschuss
geraten das video einer dash kämen die
aufnahme stammt aus einem regionalen
telekom kanal
wir werden es niemals schaffen auf
ukraine steht dort wir wurden von
panzern beschossen
maschinengewehre
essent schüsse zu hören
rechts unten die scheibe wird getroffen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rund neun kilometer liegen zwischen dem
ort an dem auf die autos und das
rentnerehepaar geschossen wurde und
einer tankstelle zwischen den dörfern
ria und mila
diese tankstelle wird zum tatort eines
kriegsverbrechens gefilmt von einer
aufklärungsdrohne
[Musik]
am 05 06 märz kreist eine ukrainische
aufklärungsdrohne über russische
stellungen nahe der tankstelle zwei
wochen nach kriegsausbruch befinden sich
die russischen angreifer in einem
schlechten zustand
es gab sowohl probleme bei den bei der
unterkunft es gab probleme selbst bei
der versorgung mit nahrungsmitteln und
insofern haben die russischen soldaten
dann begonnen zu sehen wo sie was er
kriegen also aus der umgebung es gab
berichte darüber dass sie schlichtweg
requiriert haben oder geguckt haben aus
welchen leeren häuser man etwas
mitnehmen kann
[Musik]
am siebten märz zwischen 10 uhr 9 und 10
uhr 33 entstehen diese aufnahmen
sie zeigen die positionen der russischen
soldaten am tatort in der nähe die
besatzungen von schützen
an den kampfpanzern ist das weiße frau
gut zu erkennen
eines der zeichen der russischen
streitkräfte
die straße an der tankstelle sichern
vier kampfpanzer die geschütze sind auf
die schnellstraße gerichtet in dieser
einstellung zu sehen die mutmaßlichen
täter
14 06 ein konvoi mit flüchtlingen
mindestens zehn fahrzeuge fährt auf die
tankstelle zu
im silbernen honda maxime wenko seine
frau xenia ihr sechsjähriger sohn und
eine patentante
auch sie wollen aus der deutschen
siedlung michael lief karubi schief graf
fliehen
der fahrer des blauen subaru schildert
was in diesem moment passiert
man begann auf uns zu schießen wir
versuchten so schnell wie möglich
umzudrehen
in der vergrößerung zu erkennen dass
seiten und das heckfenster werden
getroffen
hier ist die scheibe kaputt gegangen die
kugeln trafen etwa diese stelle
einschusslöcher in den kopfstützen
hier ist die kugel durchgeschlagen hier
ist die kugel eingedrungen der zweite
durchschuss und hier der dritte
stark vergrößert ein schütze vor dem
plakat fundament ein zweiter soldat ob
er schießen wird ist unklar
am boden streifen
auf weißem papier im heck und
frontscheibe des wunder steht kindern
das auto drehte
die reifen des wagens platz
mein sohn hatte ich so ein motor gehen
aus wahrscheinlich wegen des beschusses
und der saß mitten auf der straße fest
durch die schüsse wurde die mutter
getötet weil sie mit ihrem körper das
kind geschützt hat
mein sohn stieg aus dem auto oder hob
seine arme über den kopf esri kinder
nicht schießen
maximal wenko und seine frau xenia
sterben
das enkelkind und die patentante
überleben der sechsjährige soll
inzwischen war verwandten in der west
ukraine untergekommen sein die
patentante sei in sicherheit
sie brachten meinen enkel und die
verwundete freundin der familie zu einem
graben
und dann dachten sie wurde darüber nach
was sie mit ihnen tun sollen
letztlich haben sie die beiden
freigelassen
[Musik]
zwei menschen auf der flucht erschossen
ein kriegsverbrechen dokumentiert von
einer kamera drohne
45 minuten nach den tödlichen schüssen
steht der hunde in flammen wenn dann
zivile autos gestoppt werden und auch
frauen und kinder dort sich bewegen und
aussteigen und die hände heben dann ist
spätestens der zeitpunkt gekommen wo
auch die truppe dann an der front
begreifen muss dass es hier nicht mehr
militärische operationen geht sondern
dass es sich hier um zivilisten handeln
und es gibt das tarifrecht geburt
zivilisten dürfen nicht angegriffen
werden objektiv bleibt es beim
kriegsverbrechen
es stehen zahlreiche autofahrer an der
tankstelle
ob es noch mehr opfer gibt lässt sich
aus der drohnen perspektive nicht
feststellen
am selben tag am siebten märz gegen 15
uhr will hasen nicolai zog seine familie
von der tasche seines vaters abholen und
in sicherheit bringen
bleibt dass sein haus er musste in
schutz und für kinder gefährlich und das
war so nach und nach durch gefordert
an der spitze des konvois asn nicolai
lucks vater die fahrt führt über einen
damm danach geht es dem wald entlang
richtungen shit thomas gasser auf dem
weg zur autobahn begegnen ihnen
geflüchtete die zuvor an der tankstelle
beschossen wurden und umdrehen mussten
zuerst habe ich den zurückkehrenden
autos den weg zu unserem checkpoint
gezeigt
der rentner hatte einen weg aus der
kundschaftet auf dem die
eingeschlossenen dieser thomas k
autobahn überqueren kann
die autos stehen dort wurde
um in sicherheit zu gelangen müssen die
eingeschlossenen die mehrspurige straße
überqueren auf der gegenüberliegenden
seite kontrollieren die ukraine das
gebiet wer dagegen auf t shirt thomas
cup liegt stößt auf russische panzer
[Musik]
sehen sie an dieser stelle habe ich das
zeichen gegeben
das war das zeichen für die kolonne
loszufahren
ich bin dort hingegangen ankara gezeigt
wo sie wenden
nicolai lucks familie ist an der reihe
kurz vor der auffahrt wächst die
anspannung
kennt jemand ein gebet
auf der shared thomas k autobahn
überprüft flotte mikolajczyk ob
russische panzer in sichtweite sind der
rentner gibt das signal keine gefahr
es ist nicht der letzte flüchtlings
konvoi der flotte mikolajczyk über den
ausgekundschaftet ein fluchtweg aus der
deutschen siedlung nutzt sein sohn
schätzt dass sein vater bis zu 2000
menschen über die straße des todes
geführt hat
[Musik]
im gefechtsstand einer freiwilligen
einheit in kiew dieser pilot filmte die
tödlichen schüsse an der tankstelle mit
einer handelsüblichen kamera drohne über
wochen beobachteten sie russische
positionen entlang der skitour maske
autobahn an der tankstelle könnte es
weitere opfer gegeben haben
ich denke das war dieselbe situation
am nächsten tag stand nämlich ein auto
mehr dort ich meine
102 autos
bis ende märz fliegen die drohnen
piloten aufklärungsmissionen über den
russischen stellungen geben positionen
an die ukrainische artillerie weiter
meter um meter wird die russische armee
zurückgedrängt der angriff auf kiew
scheitert nach und nach wird das ausmaß
des massakers auf der schnellstraße
erkennbar wer waren die täter und woher
kamen sie und unter wessen befehl
standen die soldaten
wir fahren auf der südautobahn können
uns ein eigenes bild von dem ort des
verbrechens machen
bislang hatten wir nur dem blickte
drohne wenn man in die richtung schaut
sieht man noch sehr viele zerstörte
fahrzeuge am freitag hieß es sind etwa
20 menschen die hier
gestorben sind wie viele es genau sind
müssen halt letztlich ermittlungen
zeigen aber das ist ausdruck eines
kriegsverbrechens
zwei menschen starben in diesem renault
als sie aus dem kopierten botschaft
angehörige wussten nicht was ihnen
zugestoßen war
[Musik]
ich bin kein forensiker
aber das sind offensichtlich
menschlicher knochen das ist die
schwägerin meines freundes
und jemand sie wurden lange gesucht
sind alles zivilisten viele rentner
sie hatten nichts mehr damit zu tun
an der tankstelle das was vom silbernen
100 von maximo wenko bricht geblieben
ist das ist das auto von genco maxxim de
wit das ist der fahrer von dem silbernen
hyundai er ist ausgestiegen aus dem auto
hob die hände schrieb kinder und wurde
letztlich
erschossen und der russische panzer
stand dort hinten etwa wo das schild
steht
das zdf hatte märz 2022 exklusiv über
die drohnen aufnahmen und die tödlichen
schüsse auf maximal wenko berichtet
seitdem ermittelt die ukrainische
staatsanwaltschaft
wir haben die leichen von maxim und
xenia identifizierten
maxime vancouver 31 jahre alt
bei der identifizierung hat uns sein
vater geholfen
ich kann mitteilen dass auf der von den
russischen angreifer kontrollierten
straße von kiel nach quito mehr
57 fahrzeuge beschossen wurden
36 tote körper wurden gefunden darunter
sind kinder
die tankstelle an der stonn oscar
autobahn ist schauplatz eines massakers
die bilder vom tatort wird kaum zu
ertragen
hier zb ein fall mit dem kia auto in dem
drei leichen gefunden worden
während der ermittlungen wurde
festgestellt
dass das auto so lange beschossen wurde
bis es explodiert
falls die leichen nicht vollständig
verbrannt waren haben die russischen
soldaten sie aus dem wagen rausgeholt in
reifen darauf gelegt und weiter brennen
lassen
[Musik]
die grünen planen mit denen die täter
die leichen abdecken
genau so eine plane lag auch auf dem
russischen panzer von dem aus die
soldaten auf die flüchtenden schoss
als nächstes wollte ich ihnen dieses
foto vom fahrzeug hier zeigen dass auch
beschossen wurde und nicht abgebrannt
ist
auf dem rücksitz wurde ein kindersitz
sowie überreste des kindlichen körpers
identifiziert
und hier sind die überreste einer
jungfrau anastasia 17 jahre alt
lassen sich hinweise finden woher die
täter kamen wir beginnen die suche im
umfeld der tankstelle
in den angrenzenden wald führten
soldaten die patentante und den sohn von
maximo wenk und xenia in einem
unterstand minuten zuvor hatten soldaten
den sechsjährigen jungen zu einem
waisenkind gemacht
in den verlassenen gefällts unterständen
finden wir eindeutige spuren
[Musik]
hier sind die russische armee hatten die
stimmen von russischen armee russische
decken
russischer schlafsack an der ski thomas
k autobahn die stelle an der der panzer
stand hier war der russische panzer
unter anderem wir wollen mal sehen ob
man vielleicht noch was finden kann
vielleicht gibt es spuren
von hier wurde auf maxi mio wenko und
seine frau befolgt
hier liegen überall patronenhülsen von
schweren waffen
manchmal findet man eben doch noch was
und zwar ist dass der kopf von einer
equipment liste also hier steht welches
equipment man an die soldaten
ausgereicht hat und sie haben dafür auch
unterschrieben also hier stehen zb die
patrone tripolis arbeitet millimeter
im formular kopf der zahlencode der
einheit 4 6 10 8 die einheit stammt aus
bulgarien
mehr als 6000 kilometer von der ukraine
entfernt
die russische republik liegt zwischen
baikal see und der mongolei die einheit
gehört der fünften panzerbrigade in ulan
ude an die hauptstadt von bujar ziehen
[Musik]
die namen aus den dokumenten lassen sich
überprüfen im wald hinter der tankstelle
finden wir diesen zerstörten panzer
im umfeld liegen waffenausgabe scheine
auf dem boden
einer der namen leutnant bebo drive
im netz entdecken gerne todesnachricht
leutnant billig tobey da lief von der
einheit 46 10 80 euro fiel am 6 märz in
der ukraine
tatsächlich zeigen unsere tollen
aufnahmen wie die stellungen am wald am
sechsten und siebten märz unter schwerem
artillerie beschuss stehen
wir fahren zum nächsten tatort er liegt
10 kilometer entfernt von der tankstelle
an dieser stelle der ski thomas k
autobahn nahmen russische soldaten den
pkw des rentnerehepaares lebte war unter
beschuss die enkelin bestätigt uns dass
es der toyota der großeltern ist
immer mehr leichen werden geborgen auf
der suche nach hinweisen auf die täter
wollen wir zu den verlassenen
unterständen woher kamen die soldaten
die auf das rentner ehepaar lebte war
schossen und original ebd war schwer
verletzten ein mitglied der
territorialverteidigung begleitet uns
erkennt die gegend alles sieht so aus
als wären die soldaten gerade ist
abgezogen
wir sind als viele verlassene stellung
von der russischen armee
was auffällt wir sehen immer wieder
koffer oder taschen die eindeutig nicht
der russischen armee gehören zum
beispiel hier ist es natürlich
vorstellbar dass diese gepäckstücke aus
den autos stammen die vorher beschossen
wurden immer wieder finden wir
schulhefte sie stammen offenbar von
rekruten hier hat ein soldat notiert wie
man schulter gestützte raketen abschießt
der eindruck dass es sich um unerfahrene
soldaten handelt verdichtet sich die
armbinde eines ausbilders
ein rekrutierungs video in dem vertrag
soldaten für panzer brigaden geworben
hat die ausbilder tragen exakt die
gleiche weiße armbinde die wir gefunden
haben in der innenseite unsere armbinde
stehen namen der rekruten und das
rekrutierungs datum vierundzwanzigster
juni 2021 auf den tag genau acht monate
bevor russland die ukraine offenbar
wurden hier entlang der straße auf der
also viele zivilisten beschossen wurden
ja quasi junge männer junger männer
eingesetzt die sich in der ausbildung
befanden bei der armee also rekruten
der verantwortung für die soldaten trägt
steht in einem weiteren dokument das wir
finden es ist ein begleitschreiben für
einen schützenpanzer bmp 30 im
dokumenten kopf der code der einheit
wieder 4 6 10 8 die einheit aus polen
unterzeichnet ist das papier mit akon
tropf der kommandeur sein vollständiger
name andrej wigdorovits kontrolle eines
der seltenen fotos in einer russischen
militär zeitschrift
russische vertrag soldaten aus dem
fernen bojahr ziehen kämpfen an
vorderster front in der ukraine
alexander gar mancher papa ist
friedensaktivistin und beraten
das sind alles irdische familiennamen
wie kommt das denn dass so viele junge
männer aus kroatien in der ukraine
kämpfen
wir müssen verstehen dass es bei dem
nikotin in 23 jahren nicht geschafft hat
russlands wirtschaft zu entwickeln
gurría ziehen das ist eine der regionen
denen es sehr schlecht um
aus der finanziellen misere
herauszukommen haben junge menschen zwei
möglichkeiten
arbeit im norden russlands auf oder sie
werden beruf sollte
inzwischen konnte die ukrainische
staatsanwaltschaft im fall der familie
kopien einen verdächtigen ermitteln
der soldat kam aus einer berüchtigten
einheit
wir haben seine armee einheit
identifiziert
es ist ein soldat der 64 schützen
brigade der russischen föderation der
regierung
genannte militäreinheit hat den wald von
der stadt buschehr bis zur schickt
thomas k autobahn okkupiert
die 64 brigade wird von die
kriegsverbrechen in guter verantwortlich
gemacht putin zeichnete sie kürzlich für
ihren einsatz in der ukraine aus
die brigade ist in der region schabow
stationiert im äußersten osten russlands
9000 kilometer von der ukraine entfernt
die überlebenden und die familien der
opfer der russischen kriegsverbrechen
fordern gerechtigkeit doch selbst wenn
sich eines tages täter verantworten
müssen wird für alina cucina und ihre
tochter nichts mehr so sein wie es war
ich muss jetzt vater und mutter mir
fällt es aber sehr schwer unsere familie
ist zerbrochen
unsere pläne wurden zerstört meine
tochter sagt mir ist dass alle haben
einen vater und ich habe keine familie
ich sage ihr dass ich und du wirst die
familie sie haben unsere familien
zerstören ich weiß nicht wie ich das
überleben was wird mit dem can
die shit thomas otto bahn ist zur straße
des todes geworden
drohnen aufnahmen zeugenaussagen und
dokumente belegen es waren russische
soldaten die auf unschuldige zivilisten
schossen bisher musste sich keiner der
täter für seine verbrechen verantworten
[Musik]